hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the creation grand
chester
and it's a game between maxima shayla
grav who won the first place uh and
vishwantan anand who won second place so
i thought it'd be nice to show a game
between the two of them it's from the
first day of the blitz section
and it's a game where maxime has the
white pieces we've already seen the
final standings but we're going to check
it out again
after we check out this game so it's
quite a nice one and maxime
really really played in great great
style in this game so i'm sure you guys
are going to enjoy it
uh without further ado let's check it
out maxine with the white pieces
opens with e4 uh anand replies with c6
he goes for the karo khan we have d4 d5
and
now e5 maxine going for the advanced
variation of the car
con bishop to f5 and now knight to f3
not going for
any any any sharper bayonet attack we
have e6 now the light square bishop has
been developed so it's okay to close
down the pawn structure on the light
squares
and bishop to e2 now so just nicely
nicely developing we have c5 now wasting
the tempo but it's a move that you
often see it's like slowly shifting to
to some sort of a
french setup first you'll play c6 and
then you will of course
attack the center with c5 so here bishop
to e3 and now
queen to b6 now putting pressure on the
b2 pawn
but this is a very well known fact that
the pawn of course cannot be captured
just knight to c3 by maxine
and the problem is if you capture this
pawn it's uh it's
such an interesting game but of course
no one plays it but i'm going to show it
to you just in case
someone plays this against you if queen
captures on b2 we're going to play
knight to b5
so makes sense the knight is under
attack we want to move it knight b5
we go after knight to c7 check which
would win the rook
and now black will play c4 now the
bishop no longer defends the knight now
black
is threatening to capture the knight
here so here first we play
rook to b1 to get the queen away from
the b file and also
uh you don't want uh the queen to be
able to give some like queen to c3 check
at any point when we deliver this uh
check so here queen captures an a2 and
now knight c7 check
king to d8 and the knight captures an a8
so we pick up this rook
and now after bishop captures in c2
attacking the queen and the rook well
now comes the move
we just play rook captures on b7 white
can give up the queen here
and after bishop captures on d1 we're
just going to play rook to b8 with
check the rook cannot be attacked via
the c7 square
as the knight defends this so half
you're gonna have to move the king and
now we just play bishop captures on d1
and now after all is said and done we
get this
extremely interesting position where
it's only only white who can be better
but
in you know if you play bullet or blitz
maybe you can do something with black
hero i mean
uh you do have the queen you have the
past tape on the past t pawn
so you know anything can happen but all
in all white simply has too much
material white has a
a light square bishop a rook and a
knight for a queen and
uh well uh with with perfect play white
will be better here
but you have to be very precise so it's
you know it doesn't hurt to
to know such things so after knight to
c3 of course not queen captures on b2 we
have knight to c6 by on end
and now we have uh castles and after
castles now it's okay to capture on b2
and this is in fact the main move that
uh
people play here so now the knight is
under attack we play queen to e1 defend
the knight here
and now c katras on d4 and now not
captures
with the knight even though that's what
you guys were looking for
but then just bishop to b4 and white
could have some problems here
since the queen is here on e1 so first
after c captures on d4
we're going to capture with the bishop
and now knight captures
knight characters and bishop to b4 so
again with the double attack on the
knight
but this has all been played before so
both of them notice now comes
rook to b1 attacking black's queen here
so here we have a trade
bishop captures on c3 rook captures on
b2 now you have to capture the queen
so bishop captures on e1 rook captures
and now as the b7 point is under attack
b6 and like i said this
has all been played before many times i
think there are over like 25 top tier
games in the database
uh with this exact same move order so
here uh uh we have h4 by maxime now
preparing to
chase that bishop on the on the king
side uh so of course
h5 preventing g4 uh we have knight
captures on f5 now e
captures and now c4 uh just uh attacking
this pawn here
and if pawn captures then we activate
our bishop very nicely so here
d4 and again there is a game in the
database where c5 was played immediately
in the game
gurishu played it against hari krishna
in the saint louis
blitz tournament last year and the game
ended in a draw but here we have rook to
d1 by maxine
and it is now only as of move 18 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
how ananda deals with this
uh rook to d8 he defends this pawn but
only now that anan moved this pawn and
made his a7 pawn vulnerable although it
doesn't seem like you can reach it
now maxine pushes c5 and now you can't
really go back because the d4 pawn would
fall
uh and i mean there is not much you can
do if you allow captures then captures
and real captures you're going to lose a
pawn
so big captures on c5 is a must play so
here b captures on c5
and now maxine gets to activate his rook
with rook to b7
and it's a very very enjoyable position
as maxine is down
uh two pawns for the moment but he has
very very active pieces so here
anand has to decide how to continue he
has to be very precise
uh one option is to just start bringing
the rook directly with rook to h6 and
then if rook captures an a7 we can shift
the rook to b6 maybe to beat you
and it's going to be a very active rook
anand decides to go from knight to e7
with the idea of knight to g6 and it
makes sense from g6 the knight
is going to attack the e5 pawn and also
guard the df4 square so you cannot
defend the e5 pawn
but that it only seems that way because
maxine captures on a7
we have knights to g6 and now comes uh
well now comes a really really awesome
move bishop to b5
check forcing the black king to move so
you cannot castle and quickly bring this
rook into the game
king to f8 and now uh well the problem
is maxime wants to play
bishop to c4 attack this pawn and it
seems like it's good for white but
knight captures an e5
and you defend the pawn with the knight
and to make matters worse you can't even
play f4 because just uh well
you're going to hang your bishop so here
maxine finds
another awesome idea and that is f4 you
just defend this pawn and of course
black will not capture on f4 or or black
might capture on f4
it's a very tricky move and in a blitz
game it's uh it's a movie you never want
to play but
uh it does appear to be the best move
for black so the point is after knight
captures on f4 we're gonna play bishop
to c4
now with with an attack on the f7 pawn
you have to defend with knight to e6 but
now rook b1 and now the rook is coming
to b7 and you're gonna wreak havoc here
along the seventh track you're gonna
have two very nice pigs here
on the seventh and uh well uh black
might be able to survive this but in a
blizz game i i don't think anyone would
want to play this
so instead after f4 we have rook to h6
by on and
now comes bishop to c4 attacking this
pawn
so knights to e7 this is how you block
the rook's defense to the f7 pawn and
now
again rook to b1 going after rook to b7
and it doesn't uh seem like there's all
that much for anand to do
it's a very very passive position for
him so he plays the only thing that's
basically left in the position that's d3
but this doesn't work for a very
specific reason so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the
absolute best move for maxime
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
it is of course bishop captures on the
three so
yes chess is that simple it would seem
just bishop captures on d3 and
the point is uh if you capture the
bishop rook captures on the three uh
rook to b8 check ends the game as black
is getting checkmated the king has no
squares
you can give up the rook first and then
it's just going to be checkmate or if
you want to you know prolong the game
for a move i know some of you guys like
to do that then you can give up the
knight
and only then give up the rook because
why not
uh and uh of course that didn't happen
after bishop captures on d3
knight the c6 was played by anand so now
he first attacks the bishop and also
the rook and now uh now the bishop is
still
attacked so here rook to a3 now you just
bring the rook back to help out with the
defense of the bishop
but now he eliminated a very strong
spawn on head
head on d4 before he pushed it on d3 and
it's going to be
a much better game for white uh so rook
to e6
and now rook to c1 going after the c5
pawn
so knight to d4 planning for some
knights to f3 uh
tricks in the future but uh maxime says
it's not a problem just rook captures on
c5
uh we rook to e7 now preparing to double
rooks and now
rook eight to c3 now the the a pass pawn
is ready to be pushed we have rook e to
d7 and
now rook to c8 of course maxime now
wants to trade off a pair of rooks uh
and
enjoy his uh ex uh past a pawn uh well
uh without without the problem of
facing both of the rooks so here we have
knight to f3 check
uh it's a very nice trick if you capture
the knight then we can play rook
captures on d3 and now if rook captures
on the eight we're just going to capture
back
and of course when you're down upon in a
position like this you always want to
have
rooks on the board you don't want to
have minor pieces on the board and of
course the side that's up upon of course
the side wants to get the rooks off the
board
and keep a minor piece or no pieces at
all that's also fine if you're up a pawn
so after knight to f3 check maxim just
goes king to f2 he says okay what do you
do now your knight is now nicely hanging
still
so rook captures on d3 we have rook
capture 78
rook captures and now king captures on
f3 and now
it's still uh rook uh and uh
uh we still have a rook send game and
it's gonna be a bit harder to push that
past pawn
uh but uh the position is a most
interesting one so here uh we have rook
to d8 and it's a very interesting
decision
uh it's always uh it doesn't matter who
who's playing
whether it's carlson where it's caruana
you always have to decide whether you
want to put the rook do you want to go
to
for uh for a nice active square here
like rook to d2 or do you want to put
the rook uh well in front of the pass
pawn with rook to e8 and it's always a
deadly decision the engine enjoys both
of them anand prefers rook to d2 so here
we have a3
everything is nicely defended now king
to e7 anand starts bringing his king
into the game
and for the moment you still have this
pawn here so you can start advancing
your king so
g3 king the e6 and now king the e3
uh we rook to d1 and now uh well you
have to
try to uh advance the position somehow
you can't really push a4 because alan
will just play rook to a1 you can't
bring the king into the game because the
rook is
cutting the king off from entering the
game via the d-file
so of course maxime has to play rook to
d3 now he creates sort of a bridge here
and now his king can cross
into the game so rook to a1 king the d4
this was unstoppable so king to d7 by
allowing your own king into the game you
also allow anand's king into the game
because now the king is blocking the
rook here
so king d7 king to c5 opening up a
discovery here king to c7
and now rook to c3 just stopping any
check from behind and you are also
keeping an eye on
uh on everything here and it's it's not
just that
maksim is up upon and also has a doubled
f pawn so that's also to be
considered so here rook to d1 but now a4
maxim starts pushing his pass pawn we
rook to d2
now comes a5 now rook back to a2 uh
anand again puts his rook behind the
pass pawn but now
king the b4 with check king to b7 and
now
rook to a3 now as maxime is up this
past pawn of course anand cannot afford
to go into
uh king and pawn end game because while
the black king will be busy be
busy attacking this pawn we're just
going to march our king over to the king
side gobble up all of the pawns and then
it's going to be a very easy victory
so instead after rook to a3 we have rook
to c2
but now comes a6 with check king to a7
and king to b5
we rook the c1 by maxine and now comes
rook to d3 and he was in this position
on mu 48 that vishwanathan anand
resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
the problem is uh
there's just no way to stop uh some like
rook the c7 check and then you're just
gonna pick up the pawns
uh or you know uh if even if you try
something like rook the b1
check a king c6 and you pick up this
point you're getting checkmated rook day
three checkmate
uh so there's really no no good way to
you know do anything about this if you
play something like rook the c7
uh then you know we can just bring this
rook and start attacking the spawns here
and
there there's not all that much black
can do black and just wait and see and
see what happens uh sure
after rook to d3 anand resigned and an
amazing victory by maxime bashir lagrave
in this highly highly technical game and
let's not forget this was only a blizz
game five minutes per players
with a three seconds increment so really
really awesome stuff and so i don't
forget uh for those of you who maybe
haven't seen the previous game
i suggest you check it out because it's
a really nice one a nice
nipple versus uh on game these are the
standings
after uh all has been said and done
after
uh three days of rapid and two days of
blitz so maxine bashar agra wins the
tournament
uh with 23 points so two full points
ahead of vishwanathan anand in second
place
uh then it's anish giri with 20 and a
half uh then
uh a shared place yanipo machenyanguda
with 15 and a half then uh shared uh
kasparov shah rich
second to last place with 12 and a half
and jvf uh with
10 and a half in last place so really an
awesome tournament
and yeah hope you guys enjoyed it uh
there were plenty of
plenty of crazy games but it's often the
case when gary caspar rejoins us to you
know
play some chess we will mostly cover his
games because you know i don't know
about you guys but i'm always
super excited when he's coming back and
i don't think even because uh
he okay he didn't do that great this
tournament this could even be the the
worst tournament of his life
but i don't think uh he's gonna you know
just stopped playing i i
think we can expect him back the the
next year and the next year
i think he's going to be much much
stronger than in this one but we'll see
who knows what happens it's always
interesting when he comes back
uh so once again i hope you guys enjoyed
it that we're continuing the uh the uh
world cup now that has started uh also a
super important tournament so
hope you guys are ready for that uh i
would like to thank uh and jim
al boyd chris adrian.com christopher
marchetti and david kimura for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing well everything that uh we
always mention
uh so yeah stay tuned for that and have
an excellent rest of your day